hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com so for those who don't know
me yet let me quickly introduce myself
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past
six years in hong kong on the option
market and i've decided to make a
youtube channel a few months ago
because i want to show you guys how
protraders are actually working all the
different tools and techniques that i
use at work that work for me
and most importantly guys i want to show
you how to use it yourself
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and basically how to make
money on the markets you guys are in the
right place so
today i want to make an update on
gamestop let's get into it
[Music]
the last time i did some technical
analysis on gamestop
i was basically telling you guys that
we're looking for
as always when we do technical analysis
we're looking for supports
and resistance the support are quite
obvious i'm not gonna
explain it here again but we have the
175
and most importantly we have this
downward sloping trend line
that we broke here guys and here i gave
you this trend i told you that once we
break it this is what we're looking for
and
that there's gonna be a retest that
happened here at 160
and that this is the level you might
want to buy then
i was saying that basically we're
looking for resistance areas
and it was not that obvious and i showed
you that on the four was time frame i
did my video here
we had this 50 period moving average
this is the simple one
that is basically containing the price
as you can see and look
guys i did my video here and look how
perfectly it worked
on the next days it was here and then we
have one two
three four five you can see guys that
this is going lower
and you know the resistance area is very
obvious
so right now what is happening guys it
looks like we are breaking out
but once again a breakout you need to
have two consecutive candles on the time
frame you are watching
above the resistance that you are
considering so here we have
the beginning of a breakout but the
breakout has not happened yet
so the friday session in the u.s has
already happened and basically nothing
happened
so we closed at 190 and this is uh the
end of the week
closing price so let's see what happens
on monday
but to me this is rather bullish once
again if i do some
idiot wave counting guys so here i
showed you that i can see one two three
four
five all right
and here i'm sorry i don't have my abc
yet maybe i can
find it if like you know i do it here
but it's not very clean
so maybe we're gonna have something like
this like a flat correction
all right maybe we're gonna revisit the
175
area one more time before going uh
higher
so once again for those who interested
into like idiot wave counting
just click on the link in the
description of this video and you're
gonna receive a free training
right away guys that i i did and that is
like
really helpful for those who want to
understand the basics affiliate wave
theory
that i got by reading the book which is
very complicated i needed to read it a
couple of times so
right now guys there is something else i
want to show you i'm not sure what's
going to happen
but maybe you move down before or move
up like slightly
to 175 and then we're gonna have this
move up i'm waiting for
and i showed you guys that you know the
open interest on their prematurity is
very
high so if we starts going higher
there's going to be a lot of bullish
momentum in this market
and there is something else that is very
interesting look at this
so the first thing i wanted to say is
like why is this
actually 50 period moving average acting
so well as a resistance
and the answer is i'm not sure i don't
really know you know it's just happening
like this
i guess it's because most of people see
it this is one possibility
the other one is just that there are
patterns in the market and the price
action is just following some code
and once you know you decrypt this code
which is what i'm trying to do every day
when i do technical analysis
you have some information that is
available to everyone but only you can
see
all right and here i have something else
that is similar to
this 50 period moving average that i
showed you guys it was a pattern that i
identified and that got followed i'm not
sure exactly
why like i said it's been years i'm
doing this and it's just happening this
way
so let's just accept that and here look
what i have
so this are the volumes don't you see a
pattern
here don't you see a beautiful pattern
guys you know very high volumes price
action getting
higher then volume getting lower lower
lower and suddenly bomb
again with the price action developing
higher and here we have the same
phenomenon
the first wave in volume was a bit
steeper but definitely the volumes are
going lower guys and what we are looking
for
for a big move to happen is actually
those volumes
to uh kick off and start to you know go
above
one million shares and then we gonna
have
this strong move up again so this is to
me giving a time
horizon information because those
volumes they cannot go to zero guys all
right
so before the 7th of april we're gonna
break this trend line
trend lines work on the volume as well
and when we're going to break this trend
line there's gonna be more you know
people are gonna talk about gamestop
people are gonna trade gamestop there's
gonna be a whole uh bullish momentum
around
uh this stock and like i showed you guys
in my other videos
we're gonna have this short interest
increasing on the upside the
synthetic shot that is right now around
25 if you want to know how i compute it
just go
check my videos where i explain this on
the synthetic short and it's growing on
the upside
up to 50 60 so this is what we're
looking
for but we need something to start this
strong move up guys
so like i said just to sum up uh maybe a
small move down
next week i expect a bullish week let's
be honest maybe monday tuesday a bit
like week
low volumes again but before the end of
the week i think we're gonna see
something huge happening i think we're
gonna see maybe one move down
before a strong move up you know buying
the deepers coming in the game
and then there's gamma that is gonna
start to uh kick off
for the professionals that have the
short interest so guys that's it for me
i hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys